also vorne weg ich denke sie macht eine
super arbeit in deutschland können sich
schüler länder eine scheibe von
abschneiden
und dass man vorne weg danke und ja wie
ich wahrscheinlich sie auch und viele
deutsche fußball fans in deutschland und
natürlich meine kölner fans wo ich
ständig um anrufe bekomme fragen sich
wann können wir wieder in die stadien
dann können wir wieder in die stadien
also wir haben ja jetzt schon die ersten
stadien mit zuschauern gesehen
die letzten tage was ja eigentlich
vereinbart ist zwischen bund und ländern
das ist das thema ist ja hier das eine
ist ein konzert an einem ort an einem
abend bundesliga ist halt natürlich eine
bundesweite veranstaltungen gleichzeitig
in mehreren bundesländern wenn er alle
drei bundesligen nehmen in allen 16
bundesländern wo es dann eigentlich sinn
macht aus meiner sicht jedenfalls auch
gleiche stadt punkte zu haben das war
eigentlich vereinbart dass wir ab ende
oktober also bis ende oktober die
konzepte erarbeitet werden die zeitpläne
und dann schrittweise losgehen kann
jetzt haben wir schon einige stadien
gesehen wieder mit zuschauern
auch da ist es ja entscheiden
miteinander dass das zu üben so zu sagen
weil natürlich fußball je nachdem wie
die fans so drauf sind wir müssen halt
immer sehen es gibt natürlich
situationen und ich war selbst ich mir
jetzt abo dann meistens mit meinem
bruder dann er auch im stadion
der ist nämlich der begeisterte fußball
fan von beiden ich bin der hoffentlich
fc köln fußball hoffentlich erst
entwickeln es ist es ist ein anderer
verein in nrw aber immerhin fast
unabhängig tag warnt aber es ist
klappbar oder leverkusen um nein keine
sorge aber jedenfalls weiß ich doch wie
das ist wenn man mitfiebert wenn man im
zweifel nach dem tor sich auch in den
armen liegen will und natürlich im
zweifel nachher auch feiern und zusammen
hüpfen was weiß ich will und das
sozusagen nicht zu haben erstmal sondern
mit abstand mit mit konzepten beim
reingehen beim rausgehen dass nicht alle
gleichzeitig gehen das ist das worum es
jetzt geht das zu üben wir sehen stadien
haben jetzt gesehen das wo das wann das
soweit ich das beurteilen kann gut
geklappt hat und deswegen um
frage zu beantworten bin ich sehr sicher
werden wir jetzt zug um zug sehen dass
die bundesliga insgesamt auch mit
zuschauern spielen wird aber er möchte
wissen wann ich kann jetzt kein genaues
datum für alle nennen weil das
tatsächlich die bundesländer diesem fall
nordrhein westfalen auch nach dem
lokalen infektionsgeschehen werden
entscheiden müssen ich kann auch sehr
genau warum wir da so zurückhaltend sind
herr podolski einfach nochmal zur
erinnerung ich weiß noch sehr genau wann
ich mich entschieden habe öffentlich zu
sagen wir sollten jetzt
großveranstaltungen mal besser lassen
eine zeit
das war nach dem spiel jetzt überlege
ich gerade mal mönchengladbach sogar
wenn mich nicht alles täuscht weil es
direkt in dem land kreis heinsberg war
und wir alle haben gedacht es kann doch
nicht sein dass direkt neben dem kreis
wo wir mit abstand die höchsten
infektionszahlen in ganz deutschland
damals hatten tausende auch aus dem
kreis möglicherweise dann da ins stadion
gehen eng miteinander und wir das was
wir zu karneval schon erlebt hatten ein
paar tage vorher dann möglicherweise
noch mal im fußball stadion erleben das
war ja einer der gründe warum wir dann
da auch so klar wann gegangen sind dann
haben wir jetzt begonnen wieder ohne
zuschauer zu spielen ich denke das war
schon mal wichtig für die bundesliga
sowohl für die fans wie auch durchaus
für die wirtschaftliche lage der vereine
dass das wieder gehen kann und für die
spieler ist ja auch gut wenn wieder
gespielt wird
aber klar ist die stimme ist die
stimmung schöner wenn auch zuschauer
dabei sind und ich bin sicher das werden
wir jetzt eben zug um zug allerdings
wieder stadion noch nicht wieder gleich
ganz voll sein das glaube ich kann ich
sicher sagen
zug um zug daneben starten werden helfer
dort sind sie zufrieden mit der antwort
des ministers oder haben sie sich da
mehr klarheit der haus 9 also wie gesagt
viele vereine verantwortliche und fans
war natürlich eine stadion aber man muss
auf die leute in der politik das
vertrauen
und ja die leute haben die meinung die
leute entscheiden und am ende muss ist
jemand entscheidend und da müssen wir
auf die politik hoffen und irgendwann
während die fans wieder ins stadion
kommen
köppel und ich hoffe dass für die
bundesliga dann ja bald wieder ein
freund stadion sehen wann es dann so
weit wird entscheidet die politik bis
dahin müssen wir uns gedulden und vom
fernsehen zu schauen
ich glaube wieder sagen dass die ersten
zuschauer sehen wir haben wir auch schon
gesehen wären wir schon in den nächsten
wochen bis ende oktober soll dieses jahr
spätestens dann auch für alle das
gesamtkonzept gehen als dfl konzept ist
ja auch gut
auf dem papier ist es super ich sage
halt nur immer papier ist das eine auf
dem platz sozusagen im stadion ist das
andere
ganz vollen stadien denke ich werden wir
allerdings erst im nächsten jahr
frühestens wieder sehen das muss man
dazu sagen aber dass dieses jahr mit
zuschauern wird begonnen werden können
und erster stadien haben wir ja gesehen
da bin ich sehr optimistisch dass das
auch flächendeckend gelingt können sie
den herrn podolski hoffnung machen dass
sie druck machen auf die
ministerpräsidenten dass jetzt alle
gemeinsam als wir haben ja vereinbart
dass bis ende oktober für alle 16
bundesländer zusammen ein konzept da ist
wie unter welchen bedingungen
unternehmen auch nach der jeweiligen
infektions lage das dann dann losgehen
werden aber die erfahrungen von diesem
wochenende werden sicher dazu führen
dass ist zug um zug hat ja eigentlich
schon begonnen
ich bin jetzt auch losgehen